good morning everyone I have really
nothing to say other than it's almost
inexpressible how happy this event makes
me and to see so many familiar faces
gathered together to discuss Horace
Walpole's Castle of Otranto and really
in so doing to to commit and bear
witness to what we care so deeply about
and our shared endeavor so I can't tell
you how much I'm looking forward to this
afternoon welcome and I'm now going to
pass the mic over it is a special
occasion and I just want to since the a
nice portrait is behind me to honor the
founders of this wonderful resource the
Walpole library Wilmarth and Henny Lewis
their vision and their scholarship
really resounds out to this moment and
this treasure of a place is one that
I've returned to often and with
gratitude and I welcome you to it my job
today is just to keep the time basically
and we're going to be mindful of ten
minutes for each of the speakers I do
want to say though by way of preface
this occasion reminds me of a program we
had here at the Walpole which was a
follow-up to Yale's tour Centennial
Conference on Andy theatricality and it
was called the country house weekend and
those of us who were involved in the
conference decided not to do a co-editor
collection but rather to meet a year
later and talk about what we had done at
the conference and what our work had
generated since that point and out of
that came not just out of that
conference alone but it gave its
inflection to Felicity North palms rival
Queens to Lisa Freeman spoke on any
theatricality to Juli stone Peters the
theater in the book to my work it and
others that came out of this opportunity
so I want to capture some of the spirit
although I don't know that we'll have 10
or 12 books on Castle of Otranto
excellent as that would be I hope it
will be generative in that way because
it was the conversation it was the sense
of the galvanic intellectual moment of
we who loved the 18th century gathered
together to talk about one of its one of
its works I hope it will generate that
the kind of excitement we did on that
previous occasion as a matter of fact
I'm confident it will knowing these
speakers I'm going to introduce each of
the speakers in order and then let them
take the floor first let me welcome
Sandra Macpherson associate professor of
English at Ohio State University author
of course of harm's way tragic
responsibility in the novel form from
Hopkins in 2010 and an essay the
political fallacy which is due out in
PMLA next month I believe so this month
yeah right okay it's now a alert PMLA
right now and coming a book called the
shape of form on next jesse Molesworth
on my left associate professor of
English at Indiana University and of
course you will know him from chance and
the 18th century novel realism
probability and magic so the end of the
table there on my left Ron silver is
associate professor of literature at the
University of Michigan is currently
working on a history of complexity from
its conceptual origins in the philosophy
crafts and arts of 17th century Britain
to its emergence in theories of
self-organization in the mid 19th
century that's a lot in a sentence but I
just want to give a moment of a shout
out to a book that I've been editing
with Maggie former director here at the
Lewis Walpole Maggie Powell on hair in
the 18th century and the essay by Sean
is
related to this work about hair as
product as med Master metaphor for the
underlying organization of intellectual
life and practical life in the 18th
century so I'm I just want to make that
note about the connection there
then of course Cynthia Wall professor of
English at the University of Virginia
author of the prose of things
transformations of description in the
18th century and the literary and
cultural spaces of restoration and here
I just want to make a shout out to the
work of professor wall which has been
generative in my own I just want to say
that publicly and put it on the record
as we hear for posterity and then Gina
zorroski is associate professor of
English and cultural studies at McMaster
University an editor of the journal 18th
century fiction she's writing a book
about funniness and has a lot to say
about Walpole's Nautilus cup in case
you're interested and of course we are
we insist on your account of that as
well as your account of the Castle of
Otranto
so that is my introduction and without
further ado I turn it over to our
speakers it's me right it is ok thank
you so much Joe and thank you to
Jonathan Antin a Cole and everyone
involved in arranging this extraordinary
event I'm so moved and honored to be
here among people I respect so much many
of whose books and essays I've been
teaching this semester so it's been a
special treat to see you in the flesh so
I'm a bit chagrin to be going first
since I'm going to be violating the law
that Jonathan sat down right off the bat
which was to be you know spontaneous
which I am incapable of being so because
I can't think without writing some stuff
so here's my recent thoughts on the
Castle Tonto so I returned to
castle with tronto in the context of a
graduate seminar I'm teaching this
semester on description we began with
theoretical work in literary criticism
and art history on the descriptive turn
post critique surface reading actresses
still-life formalism and we've been
moving week by week through descriptive
genres and modes of writing from
Cooper's Hill to a hundred and twenty
days of Sodom so the question motivating
this endeavor at least for me is what
would a descriptive poetics look like
not only for our field but in general
would it be a kind of ekphrasis itself
is it possible to describe verbal
objects without interpreting them can or
does literary criticism practice literal
or surface reading it seems to me that
for the most part we don't heather love
for example seeks to appropriate for our
discipline forms of close attention that
because they offer descriptions of
surfaces operations and interactions
bypassed she says the metaphysical and
humanist concerns of hermeneutics but
when she turns to describe a literary
text Toni Morrison's beloved description
looks a lot like interpretation love
says she wants to follow up on a
suggestion by Stanley Crouch mostly
ignored by later critics that Morrison's
primary gift is one of neutral detailed
description quote he cites a passage
approvingly where Seth umekes biscuits
she recounts yet she also insists that
biscuit making is not and can never be
mere biscuit making that instead of
providing a background for the events of
the novel Morrison's descriptions are a
vehicle for a critique of historical
reclamation indeed she concludes that
Morrison's account of dehumanization
contrasts with Goffman's assiduously
neutral portraits of social interactions
and with litters refusal of humanist
ethics and she remains quite committed
to this contrast a turn from
interpretation to description might be a
way of giving up the ghost of a
unikz of empathy and recognition she
reflects but who among us is willing to
exchange the fat and the living for the
thin and the dead so I think maybe I'm
willing to make that exchange and I
think maybe Walpole is willing and
perhaps the Gothic is entirely
predicated on this exchange of the fat
and the living for the thin and the dead
but even this is too substantive a claim
for a rigorously descriptive poetics as
I said I'm not sure what Goffman's
assiduous neutrality would look like for
literary criticism maybe I will know by
the end of the semester for now I'm
simply going to share with you my
experience of returning to the Castle of
Otranto with a different set of
questions and commitments then I had the
last time I read the novel then I was
reading it for my book harm's way and I
was tracking the logic of action at a
distance of proximate causation of
strict liability I was interested in how
Jerome and Hippolyta are causes of
Matilda's murder the former because he
creates the sexual jealousy that sends
Manfred after Theodore and Isabella the
latter because she literally dispatches
Matilda to Theodore as an intercessor on
behalf of Manfred had I managed to get
my thoughts together enough to include
the Castle of Otranto in my book I might
have said something like the Catholic
logic of intercession the practice of
deputizing an agent to act on one's own
or a third party's behalf is more
essential to the way the novel works
through the problem of responsibility
than the idea of original sin pointed to
in waffle Walpole's preface I would have
attended to the centrality of object
agency thing liability and its converse
the instrumentalization d
personification of human agents and i
would have insisted that strict
liability for the effects of actions not
in any immediate way one's own is the
Gothic I might still say this and I
guess I actually have just said it but
in the book I'm completing now these are
the sorts of things that interest
although in the preface to the second
edition Walpole satirizes a naive
mimesis that would have Rosencrantz and
Guildenstern describes Krantz described
for Guildenstern the iconography of the
Palace of Copenhagen the Castle of
Otranto at least for this reader is all
about doors gates windows floors
chambers casements and stairs the
dominant formal feature of the novel is
what one might call chrono topic
description at rope ology of space and
movement this is not I think equivalent
to what cindy via henry Peacham calls
pragmatic raffia here is no investment
in energiya in vividness of description
rather these architectural forms are
what George Kubler would call primary
objects forms whose function is to be
undifferentiated the same shape always
and everywhere the importance of these
forms the way they take up space yet in
the way especially of the unfolding of
the incidents of plot and their meaning
is parodied in the slapstick exchange
between Jack ways and Diego who
frustrate man for his desire to know
what they have seen by dis coursing at
large on how doors open and shut and
it's that great you know a clown moment
later this parody is ratcheted up in the
procession of the stranger Knight and
his train which is a cavalcade of
nothing so much as metonymy two trumpets
a hundred foot guards as many horse each
phrase an example of the indexing of an
object in this case a human person by
her attributes Manfred for his part is a
parvenu of suspicious reading coming
upon Conrad's body mangled beneath the
helmet he's entirely indifferent to the
banal facticity of the corpse preferring
instead to focus attention on the object
that calls out to be read allegorically
or emblematical e the the helmet
Hippolyta on the other hand is
indifferent to anything but the death of
her son we're told so at the very outset
Walpole stages in opposition between
literal and hermeneutic attention and
indeed one could say that the NA
is a Fantasia of literalization and in
particular a literal izing of verbal
artifacts a kind of reverse a traces of
the claws grown too large to inhabit
this is one way to understand the other
thing that is currently obsessing me
which is the sheer number of exclamation
points and M dashes in the orthography
and typography of the text this too is
literal ization we are told that Manfred
is brought to his senses to register
Conrad's demise by a folly of
ejaculations and what is the Castle of
Otranto but such a folly of ejaculation
the novel is built upon intensifying
scenes of exclamatory and interrogative
speech and the two practices of
literalization are brought together of
literal izing in objects lexical units
and and literal izing the content of the
the effective content of lexical units
in punctuation are brought together as
the novel unfolds especially in the
scene between manfred and the sighing
Knight where the former's ejaculations
register speech on the part of the
knight that as a narratology smite se is
dis narrated pointed to but not
represented a dyke this an act of
pointing that points to instead bodily
morphology the shake of the head that is
the identical characteristic movement of
the helmet plumes so this is about as
far as I've managed to get in my
thinking someone else might want to say
something substantive about
fragmentation interruption the link
between these formal features and the
thematics of usurpation but in
conclusion I just want to point to
Bianca's description of the gigantic
animated statue it she says as big as
big - a failed simile that in issuing
indexicality prevents reading a dykes
estat points to the attributes of a
thing without explaining it this in a
very literal sense is what the castle of
Toronto for me is about if aboutness is
the right word
Jessie Thanks to everyone this is a you
know been a fabulous event and thank you
for coming so this paper is an extension
of an article I wrote on Walpole several
years ago called gothic time sacred time
and in that essay I argued that there is
such thing as the Gothic clock trope
that is to say that in the gothic time
is not really out of joint as someone
like Derrida argues rather it's both out
of joint but also aggressively what I
call in joint that is to say that
there's a precision to the timing of the
actions of events in the Gothic and
especially an interest in the hour of
their occurrence and maybe the emblem
for that might be the bleeding none in
the monk who appears on the 5th of May
every fifth year as soon as the clock
strikes one so the point that I made in
this essay was that his phenomenon seems
rooted in a very odd decision to me and
that is Walpole's decision to write a
novel that obeys the unity of time that
is to say that you know we know that
this plot unfolds over a you know
roughly evenly spaced period of three
days it's in the same location so it
also obeys the unity of space during
these three days the passage of time is
regularly marked not really by the the
number of the hour but by natural
signifiers sunrise sunset but also by
supernatural signifiers as well so that
you know the appearance of the helmet
the foot the sword the arm of Alfonso
seemed to operate like ticks in some
type of clock that is gradually winding
in any case there's a you know a clock
like treatment of time in the castle of
a Toronto I mean it's always been
shocking shockingly odd to me the
interest in the unity of time and you
might say well it creates the the
dramatic structure of the novel in the
sense that the five chapters feel like
the five acts of a play and you know
maybe it enhances
the Shakespearean character of the novel
but we also have to remember of course
that Shakespeare is you know famous
ultimately for denying the unities and
so there's something you know I think
also profoundly unshaken about that
decision so in any case since I wrote
that essay which was on Walpole and
Lewis and Radcliffe I've become
interested in kind of tracking this
gothic clock trope in two subsequent
fictions that have been influenced by
the Gothic so weathering Heights great
expectations and the rest of this paper
is actually on mrs. Dalloway which is a
novel that you know I think has you know
increasingly seen within the Gothic
tradition particularly following Paul
st. amorous book
Virginia Woolf novel mrs. Dalloway
features an array of clocks meticulously
marking the passage of time over the
course of a single June day in 1923 the
Westminster neighborhood in which the
novel is primarily set to clocks just
with one another for primacy there is of
course the masculine figure of Big Ben
who's ringing is heard on five separate
occasions and there is st. margaret's
the church whose bells are personified
as the feminine counterpart to Big Ben
so this is from the novel ah said st.
margaret's like the hostess who comes
into her drawing-room on the very stroke
of the hour and finds her guests there
already I am NOT late Big Ben and st.
margaret's therefore express themselves
as versions of Richard and Clarissa
Dalloway the married couple whose story
forms the core of the novel set to ring
two minutes after Big Ben
st. Margaret seems scarcely more than an
echo of its more prominent competitor
much of the way that Clarissa now
devotes much of her own life to
supporting the work and professional
life of her husband a Conservative MP
the set up is therefore not unlike that
found in the monk in which the masculine
monastery Bell and the feminine convent
Bell just with one another sending the
students or the citizens of Lewis's
Madrid to perform tasks at their
appointed hour mrs. Dalloway it is big
ben for example that informs us that the
time is the early morning during the
novel's opening scene ten o'clock
seemingly
clarissa sets off to buy flowers for the
party she is scheduled to host later so
they're out it boomed first a warning
musical than the our irrevocable the
leaden circles dissolved in the air and
it's more sub-sect subsequent
appearances Big Ben marks the time very
carefully as 11:30 a.m. noon 3:00 p.m.
and 3:30 p.m. the effect therefore is
partially to instill a sense of time
discipline on a novel that lurches
through various memories across vast
stretches of time more insistently
though Big Ben's carefully marked rings
bear out the formal oddness that the
novel happens to share with the cast of
Otranto it also obeys Aristotle's unity
of time and in fact you might say this
is one of the very few novels written
since the Castle of Otranto that obeys
the unity of time mrs. Dalloway of
course features no actual ghosts but it
does feature an array of characters who
are haunted in various ways according to
the logic suggested by Terry Castle
where the mind has become a world of
phantoms consider the case of Septimus
Warren Smith the poet and soldier whose
story of shell-shocked trauma intersects
with the main plot between these two
roles poet and soldier critics have had
much to say about the latter a little to
say about the former this imbalance is
unfortunate first because the poet's
love of words expresses itself strongly
throughout Septimus internal monologues
and second because words frequently
trigger
Septimus as traumatic flashbacks to his
life as a soldier and one of these words
happens to be time so this is from the
novel it is time said Reza the word time
split its husk poured its riches over
him and from his lips fell like shells
like shavings from a plane without
making them hard white imperishable
words and flew to attach themselves to
their place in an ode to time an
immortal ode to time he's saying
Evans sang among the orchids there they
waited for the war till the war was over
and now the dead
now Evans himself for God's sake don't
come Septimus cried out and for he could
not look upon the dead under his command
as poet the word time was once an ally
attached to his most ambitious poem and
immortal ode to time here though it has
become his enemy attached to both the
memory of his dead friend Evans
whose spirit haunts Septimus throughout
the novel and to the unwelcome
suggestion from his wife that his
psychiatrist dr. Bradshaw is expecting
them soon in fact in the hands of dr.
Bradshaw time has become something else
entirely
whereas for the poet Septimus it is an
abundant resource something that pours
its riches over him for the psychiatrist
Bradshaw is a scarce commodity something
to be managed and rationed to his
patients he gave three quarters of an
hour Wolf's personification of Big Ben
is masculine source of authority
therefore reaches its zenith in his
presentation of Bradshaw the
psychiatrist in the mind of someone who
worships proportion divine proportion
Big Ben might be seen as its earthly
minister carving ours proportionally
into quarters and coaching its subjects
on the practice of efficient time
management eventually of course Septimus
is davinci dementia will transform
Bradshaw
along with Holmes the physician into
minions of a Luciferian brute with red
nostrils but the novel itself is already
hinted at Bradshaw status as gothic
tormentor so this is from the novel les
passage it was precisely 12 o'clock 12
by Big Ben whose stroke was wafted over
the northern part of London blent with
that of the other clocks mixed with a
thin ethereal way with the clouds and
wisps of smokes and dry and died up
there among the seagulls twelve was the
hour of their appointment so in the
chapter that I focus on this novel this
is actually the third appointment that
takes place on the stroke of twelve the
first is from the month between the
great mogul and Don Raymond the second
is Catherine Moreland's frustrated
appointment with Elinor Tilney you know
there seems to be some type of dialogue
here
because for me in such passages the
novel translates the gothic villain into
tormenting psychiatrist
like wise Bradshaw's goddess proportion
and more emerges as a cruel
uncompromising deity on candidly
inflicting her own form of psychological
torment with an EP thompson's culture of
time discipline Septimus is final scene
finds him hiding away in the
second-story bedroom of the smith's
Bloomsbury house panic-stricken at the
sudden arrival of the physician Holmes
who has been transformed in his mind
into bradshaw's co-conspirator thus the
novel manipulates a familiar set of
gothic coordinates ultimately forcing
Septimus into the role of gothic heroine
there is also the Radcliffe Ian's tone
of dread Holmes was coming up the stairs
Holmes would burst open the door Holmes
would say in a funk eh then there is the
gruesome outcome of the scene a Septimus
commits suicide by hurling himself from
the second-story window and finally
there is the clock as well who's ringing
interrupts Razia's scattered events
reflections on the event the clock was
striking one two three how sensible the
sound was compared with the thumbprint
like Septimus himself she was falling
asleep but the clock went on striking
four five six here the clock offers
order and perhaps comfort within a scene
consumed by chaos but the irony is that
this clock along with the numerous
others seen within the novel contributes
to the set of gothic forces that
precipitate this chaos thank you
Thank You Jessi Sean one thanks Jonathan
and thanks all of you for being here I
think I may honestly say that apart from
anywhere that my wife and daughter are
there's no place that I'd rather be than
the Lewis walpole library
I intend my remarks to bear on what it
means to take the Gothic seriously and
and I mean the Gothic to refer primarily
to the architectural an aesthetic
category rather than a strictly literary
or narrative one though I hope some of
the connections will emerge over the
course of my remarks
too often we fall into a trap that
Walpole has laid for us that is of
thinking that his lightness of style
authorised as a lightness of approach
whereas taking the Gothic seriously it
means treating it as a sustained
aesthetic response to mainstream
enlightenment style including the
neoclassical aesthetic in arts and
architecture I mean to claim for the
Gothic its status as a precursor and
proving ground for complexity which I
understand is the categorical claim that
common notions or observed phenomena are
the emergent effects of relationships
between components that normally remain
invisible it's a distinction that's
important in cognitive philosophy among
other places and that's where I'm going
to start so if you were to ask someone
20 years ago to sketch out how we think
you might have seen something like I
myself am blocking it
and that's how we think yeah I guess
that's true it this is this is a
so-called functionalist architecture I'm
gonna put some pressure on that
architecture thinking imagined as a
series of components sensory input is
transformed into internal
representations which are processed
looped stored transformed converted into
motor proprioceptive output it's based
on this scheme this is the so called
Neumann architecture from john von
neumann
who at MIT in the 1940s and 50s provided
the basic structure for the modern
microcomputer that's a machine that
stores and transforms representations it
has long term memory short-term memory
and so on the crucial the crucial point
is that thinking is imagined as a system
of discrete stacked components and this
is a principle that runs all the way
down for it's also for a system like
this is also imagined to act on discrete
accumulated components as the
accumulator here I think makes
abundantly clear and that's what we in
cognitive theory now with what we what
we tend to call short-term memory that
accumulator all right if you're like me
you can't see this without thinking of
something like this this is Chyzyk house
which I choose because Walpole found it
to be exemplary of neoclassical
architecture thought sometime around
1740 8 1750 or or or perhaps the this is
the indigo Jones gate which is also on
the grounds of Chizik house it's it's
built like the Neumann architecture it's
built on a principle of stacked
components it's a design realized in
stone it's basic operative principle is
the lintel stacked on columns or blocks
stacked on blocks architecture as the
stacking of things I'm leaning on this
metaphor a little bit
I'm also leaning I suppose on the
particular magnification that images may
possible I think I have 12 images which
I mean to stand for 12,000 words but the
links have to do with the kinds of
models that will accept or the way that
we understand things to work so now if
you were to ask
someone now what to sketch out a process
of thinking you might see something like
this this is a connectionist
architecture or something like this this
is a simulation of a connectionist model
that I put together myself on sim brain
3.0 which is a Java based applet which
simulates connectionist neural
architectures on a formalist micro
computer and if you're also if you like
me and I realize at this point I may be
the only person in the room that's like
me you can't you can't think of this
without thinking of something like this
all right this is King's College Chapel
and it's an example of the Gothic or or
this which is its ceiling and it's also
the place that Walpole claimed he first
lost his heart to the Gothic there was a
tradition repeated by woful Walpole
himself that Christopher Wren would
regularly tour regularly tour the chapel
I'm suggesting that he'd be happy to
build a replica if anyone could but show
him where to lay the first stone the
joke's on a misunderstanding of the
construction principles of the Gothic
which is not about the stacking of
things but it's about lines of force
it's fundamental fundamental principle
is the rib it's a relationship that
stains a sustains a soaring space this
by the way is Walpole's homage to the
King's chapel ceiling this is the fan
vault ceiling in the gallery at
Strawberry Hill and the crucial thing
and this is one of the transformational
moments in my own intellectual career it
was a line spoken in an offhand way by
Joe Roche in a dingy room at UCLA no
persons are no people but only
relationships and which I'm extending
here no objects but only relationships
no ideas no thoughts but only
relationships that no stones here to be
stacked but only connections not
stacking but weaving the emergence of
something where there was nothing before
in general connectionists align
themselves connection is to align
themselves with a recent turn in the
scientist towards complexity and they
trace it back about 50 years to develop
developments especially with increased
computing power power in the 1960s 70s
and 80s but I'm suggesting come
like city has shadowed enlightenment
reductionism all along it's just that we
don't take these alternatives too
seriously as intellectual exercises I'm
going to wrap up or I'm going to sum up
I suppose with three provocations three
because three is the minimal number that
it takes to create a complex structure
walpole himself saw the Gothic is the
major alternative to neoclassicism from
the stately rational order of what he
called the Grecian or we the National uh
the neoclassical he opposed what he
called the liberty of the Gothic and
while most of us would be likely to
think of the origins of architecture as
a history of the stacking of stones
multiple himself was quite clear
the first architectural gesture was the
weaving of branches to form a roof right
woven rather than stacked you know I see
that repeated and the the fan vault
ceiling he has in other words flipped
the paradigm it's relationships are
prior to objects - it's about ornament
right it's a part of the legacy of the
Enlightenment to fetishize forms which
seemed to follow functions the evidently
minimalist stacked forms of the
neoclassical aesthetic would seem to fit
this criterion but a better way to think
about form is as the outward
manifestation of design principles
aesthetics as a signal of the way we
imagine things to be put together in
this light it's certainly significant
the building's light Chyzyk house or the
Indigo Jones gate here
our brick that are then covered in
stucco which is tooled to look like
blocks which makes its principles
manifest in precisely the same way that
Walpole did whose Gothic ornamentation
was historically and I think unfairly
been lambasted for being made out of
paper mache but as somehow to ornamental
or perhaps not gothic enough and also in
this light I think it's important that
repeatedly we see Strawberry Hill framed
by this kind of vegetable arches my
final point I've been arguing all along
that functionalism like the neoclassical
implies certain habits of thought the
neoclassical edifice is designed it's
held as an internal representation
before being realized in stone indeed a
representation often developed by one
man Christopher Wren for instance and
this is why it's often associated with
reason but the Gothic can have no prior
representation it's surely significant
that each major Gothic Revival was a
collaborative effort John John Ruskin
and a famously vexed love triangle and
the Scottish Highlands William Morris in
a circle of students at Oxford and of
course Horace Walpole and the committee
of tastes at Strawberry Hill the Gothic
in other words as a negotiation nobody
designed Canterbury Cathedral it evolved
in partnerships between generations of
architects builders and craftsmen and
this is why the style appealed to Ruskin
as a political program and it's why it
appealed to Walpole as an aesthetic one
because it registers a design principle
which is relational which is to say
connectionist through and through the
connectionist school is part of a recent
turn to complexity in the sciences
generally pitches itself as a radical
alternative to the legacy of
Enlightenment reductionism an
alternative roughly forty or fifty years
old
but as I've been suggesting complexity
has existed alongside functionalist
explanations all along it's only that
until we're willing to accept ornament
as essential rather than superficial
we're unlikely to see the Gothic as
anything other than a self-indulgent
aesthetic experiment put differently
establishing an alternative to the
burden of enlightenment the burden of
the Enlightenment in modern
thought begins I'm suggesting by taking
the Gothic at least as seriously as we
take the neoclassical including
architectural projects like Chyzyk house
but also the functionalist paradigm to
which it gives rise thank you Shawn
Cindy I have a handout that actually
involved cutting and scotch tape and
magic markers kind of a different take
would I do want to thank our hosts here
for what Joe has called a country-house
weekend and I'm going to begin with a
well-known Walpole's dream you just
quote it in two parts the genesis of a
Toronto of course as we all know was
when as well Paul says I waked one
morning in the beginning of last June
from a dream of which all I could
recover was that I had thought myself in
an ancient castle a very natural dream
for a head field like mine with gothic
story and that on the uppermost banister
of a great staircase I saw a gigantic
hand in armor in the evening i sat down
and began to write without knowing in
the least what I intended to say or
relate work grew on my hands and I grew
fond of it add that I was very glad to
think of anything rather than politics
huzzah for the wallet Palooza I have to
say that when Jonathan informed us that
this would be videoed recorded I said
thank you very much Jonathan and then I
promptly had a dream myself in which K
in we were all gathered here in sort of
pews and Jonathan was walking among us
in eighteenth-century Wescott's
and he said right we will proceed in
order alphabetically by costume and this
being my dream of course I had no
costume so but I'll get to the second
part of multiples quotation in a minute
my comments today come actually come out
of my classroom experience this semester
in reading a Toronto I'm teaching a
first-year course on the art of reading
and writing and it has a gothic theme
from the 18th century to the 20th from
Castelvetrano to the haunting of Hill
House and Stephen King and so we started
with Otranto and I had the required
edition was Lewis's Oxford world's
classics with Cleary's notes an
introduction and I was having the
students read things out loud assigning
them different characters and it didn't
go very smoothly because they kind of
kept tripping over each other landing in
each other's dialogue space and then
they complained there aren't any
quotation marks although then some
people said mine has quotation marks and
someone else hadn't mind us so we
started comparing editions and we talked
about the history of quotation marks for
a little bit and how in the middle of
the 18th century people often use dashes
to indicate the next speaker although
Walpole isn't very consistent in that
either and then I started thinking I
started kind of paying attention to the
sentences again and this comes out of my
book that's coming out this spring
includes a lot of attention to the
topography of the page and the texture
of prose so lots of typographical
interest going on here as well as a
history of prose rhythms and things in
general landscape of texts as well as
landscape of land and struck me that in
a at first it seemed fanciful fanciful
but then I started following it through
Walpole's
syntax is itself gothic the sentences
follow their own wee
little corridors you turn a corner and
you bump into something else you have to
look back over your shoulder to see who
was talking so I decided to you know
work through this um you know of course
we could say along with our dear mr.
Lewis who said I marvel how such a lucid
and entertaining writer is worth Walpole
could have written so confused and
clumsy a book but I will work with Sean
here and go for the importance of design
the effect for me of a Toronto has
always been the effect of design in
different ways and the more you push it
the more it hangs together and of course
loose himself was described some of the
works that came out of the press his
Strawberry Hill press is guilty of the
beautiful negligence of a gentleman but
he was also not very convincingly
self-deprecating and certainly in his
6th edition of Otranto printed by Bodoni
and parma he had so many Corrections
that had delayed the publication so he
is um was a man of detail so the rest of
that quotation in short I was so
engrossed with my tale which I completed
in less than two months that one evening
I wrote from the time I had drunk my tea
about 6 o'clock till half an hour after
1:00 in the morning when my hand and
fingers were so weary that I could not
hold the pen to finish the sentence but
left Matilda and Isabella talking in the
middle of a paragraph so my remarks
today are looking at the ends of
sentences in the middles of paragraphs
Cleary's note 2 the epigraph of Otranto
tells us that Walpole reverses the
meaning to say that nevertheless head
and foot are a sign
to a single shape I think the sentences
in that wall pulsing tactics work in
that shape as well so with the handout
the blue you marks my looking at the
ends of sentences in the very first
sentence of the very first two sentences
end with Mathilda and of course she ends
up being the the prominent one in so
many ways and that particular syntax we
might say that the dispositional II
challenged Conrad is syntactically
obliterated in those two sentences the
one on the bottom of the paragraph on
the top of page 25 so the upper right
hand corner left her in total darkness
one of the first you know gothic moves
of cliff-hanging paragraphs inventing
the tropes as we go along on the flip
side you know the events charging in it
is my child my Theodore while Lewis
himself again in another work trying to
figure out the appeal of a Toronto he
said it must be because something is
always happening the end of every
dialogue ends in an explosion well the
end of every paragraph and in some ways
the end end of every sentence ends up in
something happening one way or another
the the passage with Mathilda sinking
its manfred gliding to the death of his
daughter and then the last sentence of
the book is just not so much an
explosion but this limp thing were left
with so the anti explosion but more
interesting to
well okay the orange is other
interesting things that happen
syntactically in here 41 through 43 is
one of those places where the Gothic
starts making its own textual
subterranean spaces so Manfred
disappears for a while and comes back
and this is elaborated beautifully in
the monk and mysteries of Udolpho and
then gliding softly between another
sense of sort of form and content
there's a gliding going on in the
paragraph but most interesting to me is
those moments where one person speaking
lands in another person's territory and
that's kind of it struck me like
Sedgwick on identity and surface where
personal identity in the Gothic is at no
moment inherent in one but applicable is
applied only from outside up Raikou and
by a process of visual assimilation or
seeing as and in a Toronto your eye has
to be pretty quick and skilled you have
to kind of be familiar with the text and
the passages or the passageways of the
prose in order to navigate the turns and
assimilate the identities look on the
bottom of the front page on the left
hand side is that scene alluded to
earlier J Cui's and Diego and Manfred
all the babble is syntactically
reproduced it's a mess on the right hand
side facing it is Henry Moore Lee's 1886
Edition which is an example of beautiful
Victorian engineering everybody's
identity is carefully sorted out not
just by quotation marks but in
paragraphs we make no mistake whereas in
the Walpole itself we make the mistake
all the time it's kind of the opposite
of the primary objects in the text the
identities of the characters are you
know slide between each other and and
through the sentences so the game I was
playing with myself and then with my
students
the yellow doesn't come here through so
much but it's a it's kind of linguistic
game
I fear no bad angel and have offended no
good one and then that territory you
know he could be saying your behavior
has been so gracious to me or you know
you know but it's not is above your
seeming well somewhere we know that's
not Theodore speaking it's gonna be
Manfred and then it says left-hand side
on the second page they seem to inquire
in the eyes of their Lord what they
ought to feel surprised out tenderness
respect succeeded each other in the
countenance of the youth oops
depart it cannot be known that I
assisted thy flight swear by the Saints
above well no miss Matilda isn't gonna
be swearing okay ah rest assured that no
suspicion cannon alight on me she says
give me thy beauteous hand no until is
not gonna be asking for anyone's
beauteous hand there is not a sentiment
engraving in my heart that does not
venerate you and yours the grace and
generosity you have exhibited to your
people
no the grace and fervor with which
Theodore uttered this see all of these
not marked by dashes what deed of man
Fred authorizes you to treat him as a
murderer an assassin now virtuous gentle
maiden however you such thoughts man
Fred will never permit our union and
that it might be whoever's responding no
Vista I shall take care of everything
Oh thou of the beauteous hand no it's a
man Fred um and then I guess I just want
to end with the idea that in the middle
of that last paragraph that ends with
the limp Theodore
we've got Isabella and his dear Matilda
mixed in the middle of the paragraph so
that's my gothic excursion
Thank You Cindy Gina
so like Shaun I have been thinking a lot
lately about what it would mean to take
Walpole's gothic seriously but I've been
thinking specifically about what it
would mean to take Walpole's and the
Castle of Otranto x' funniness seriously
which means I've really been thinking
about what it would mean to take the
novels or the novellas refusal to take
certain things seriously seriously and
that's what my my talk today is about I
I was started on this this path of
thought by reading Cindy's section on
the Castle of Otranto in the prose of
things which is such a marvelous reading
of this novel and so I'm it's it's both
fun to be able to do this right after he
has presented and maybe a little bit
embarrassing but by paper is also kind
of a love letter to your section on our
Toronto in in that book so thank you
very much so my talk begins with a
narrative of the haphazard beginnings of
my current project on funniness which
was routed in various ways through
Walpole and the Castle of Otranto at its
start and I was enabled in this kind of
odd start to a book on funniness by
reading Cindy's amazing section on
Otranto in the prose of things which
reads Otranto as a kind of Swiftian
satire of the disproportionate
significance of objects in modern life
whose comedy is premise on things
literally being thrown out of proportion
right so the giant helmet is probably
the the foremost example Cindy's reading
confirmed what I always felt that
Otranto was a deeply funny book and not
just by accident or maybe by accident
but not just as a kind of effect of
failing to be funny I mean failing to be
scary
I was distracted with how funny the
helmet is in particular with its
constantly waving proportionable
quantity of black feathers
right which Cindy called at one point
the the feathers less inherently
dignified objects than helmets and
swords which which means that a lot a
lot of this project has been me thinking
about the relative dignity of different
kinds of objects a funniness only
compounded by the image of it the helmet
having squashed Conrad the feathers
waving ominously over the bleeding
mangled remains and maybe to a lesser
extent by the image of Theodor trapped
under the helmet so thinking about the
helmet in relation to these bodies that
kind of get positioned around it I
started to ask research questions why is
this helmet so funny why does it get
funnier in proximity to death is it
because I'm a horrible person or is it
doing something is it doing something I
spent a lot of time thinking about the
tableau of the scene of Conrad's death
with the same engrossment with which
Manfred of course views the single
overwhelming detail of the helmet
alright so he's you know he's transfixed
by this helmet and I spent a lot of time
just trying to imagine the scene of
Manfred looking at the helmet and the
feathers waving and the bleeding mangled
remains kind of you know doing whatever
they do messily the moment began to
strike me the moment of Conrad's death
as a very funny parody of still life a
scene of life suddenly stilled one life
because it is crushed and one because it
is transfixed and the constantly
agitated feathers seemed in a kind of
double metonymic movement to appropriate
the life that had been taken from the
two human figures in this tableau and
transfer that life inappropriately to
the helmet which remains animated
throughout the tale so I began to think
a lot about feather
this is the very beginning of a research
project so just remember this begin to
think a lot about feathers about dead
things particularly dead birds which is
where feathers come from whether they're
funny or not not in reality of course
because that would be horrible but in
representation and right around this
time I received fortuitously both a
sabbatical and a sizable research grant
from the Canadian government thank you
shirk so in pursuit of the secrets to
why things are funny I went to Europe
armed with a copy of the Castle of
Otranto and spent three solid weeks
looking at paintings of dead animals
that was the beginning of this project I
also went to the newly renovated
Strawberry Hill for the first time and
and that was pretty incredible
I was very distracted by my mission to
understand the image of dead animals
dead creatures and birds in particular
so I took a photograph of every single
bird I came across in like the
ornamentation of Strawberry Hill and I
was surprised to find there there are a
lot of them I also thought a lot about
hybrid objects or what I think of as
confused objects I mean confused as a
term that the novel uses and and I love
the the quotation from Lewis that
describes the the tail as as clumsy and
confused I come back to clumsiness kind
of towards the end here but confused
objects combining like the giant helmet
creaturely detritus and man-made
materials and and that is how I became
interested to distraction with Nautilus
cups does everyone here know what a
nautilus cup is I'm sure if anyone not
know what it so they're you sure you've
seen one but I'm not sure it registered
with you but there are these renaissance
objects made from the shell of the
chambered nautilus so that's this you
know sea creature and it has that that
spiral shell but at that large shell
it's about this big and the shells would
be polished you know so that you can the
the outer the outer layer
taken off to reveal the mother-of-pearl
there sometimes engraved but then they
would be mounted on these really
elaborate kind of like stems and
embraces to turn them into kind of you
know collectibles so I was interested in
one in particular that Walpole owned and
kept in the Great North bedchamber at
Strawberry Hill it's now in the prince
and HOF Museum in Delft although I think
there's a possibility it may be coming
too it may be coming to Yale next year
for an exhibition so just a few words
about Nautilus cups just a few so the
Nautilus Cup in which the shell of the
chamber Nautilus is mounted and
elaborately wrought metal introduces
problems of scale quite similar to those
cindy illuminates in the Castle of
Otranto in comparison to other seashells
the Nautilus is both remarkable and
valuable because it is giant ray it's a
giant sea shell but as an object
especially one in the when it's made
into the cup displaying ferocious
monsters its diminutive so it's a way of
like taking these like you know kind of
like big monsters and putting them into
a shape that you can put on a mantle
right and if we think about the interior
of the shell as a kind of grotto akin to
the space under the giant helmet in
which Theodore is temporarily imprisoned
it's a miniature it's a miniature grotto
in fact I discovered looking at a
particular Nautilus Cup that was in the
Louvre and I was so excited when I saw
this that I actually I cursed out loud
in the museum it was very embarrassing
the echoes but I saw it I looked in this
nautilus shell and I discovered small
Helms were routinely carved in the
interior of shells prepared for Nautilus
cups so that when you peer into the
chamber of the mounted shell what faces
you is a tiny helmet and I could say
more about why the artisans did this but
I don't have time right now so you can
ask me later
another thing I learned about while
researching Nautilus cups was the
phenomenon of catastrophic positive
buoyancy which is something that
chambered nautilus can experience so
that's the phrase that scientists used
to describe the fact the chambered
nautilus likes to be it's a kind of a
bottom dweller likes to be deep in the
water and it can propel itself up and
down and as well as around in the water
but if it for some reason Rises too
quickly to the surface it can't correct
course and propel itself back down and
it dies on the surface so that's
catastrophic positive buoyancy but this
strikes me as also a potential metaphor
for the feeling I associate with the
spectacle of poor Conrad's violent death
by ridiculous object catastrophic
positive buoyancy suggests to me a form
of hysterical laughter one
out-of-control and triggered as easily
by calamity disaster and violence as by
a good fortune one that is as likely to
feel painful in its excess as
pleasurable as a description of the
spirit that animates Otranto the phrase
shows us how walpole sense of humor is
in many ways more indebted to the
excesses and grotesque curries
celebrated in greek satyr plays than to
roman satire in its more exuberant
moments the Gothic pushes us to a giddy
encounter with the visceral material of
life and death in a way that seems by
measures of classical reason rather
unhinged ultimately the funniness of the
Castle of Otranto turns patriarchal
emblems and institutions into a suicidal
killing joke here I'm still following
Cindy's lead she writes in Otranto it is
almost as if the bigger the phallus the
bigger its impotence which i think is
true and this also leads me to think
back to Sandra's description of this
book as a folly of ejaculation maybe in
a in a slightly different sense the
stark and inflated hilarity of phallic
power rendered impotent is central I
would say to the funniness of Walpole's
writing and it places him in a genealogy
of both intentionally and
unintentionally funny English
letters extending at least in my project
from Eliza Heywood to Thomas De Quincey
but the failure implied in scenes of
impotence ray a failure to consolidate
to embody and to wield power is
transformed by their funniness in scenes
like these into a different kind of
agency or I would like to argue a
political a form of political promise
Cindy concludes in her reading that
Otranto cyan't things are meant to be a
bit silly pairing this observation with
Lauren Berlin's insistence on the
counter politics of the silly object
I've been trying to think about both the
cultural and political stakes of
refusing to take the giants of one's
dominant social order seriously I'm
thinking about how Otranto reveals the
clumsiness so again the clumsy that this
book is a clumsy thing the clumsiness
and agitation of patriarchal agents the
scrambling ineffectual male heroes but
also the absurd helmet kind of like
chomping around the house of how it
dares us of how the novel dares us not
to smirk at the gory revelation of their
embodied frailty those patriarchal
agents and of the spectacular
vulnerability of patriarchal lineage on
display and Conrad's bleeding mangled
remains and of how the novel refuses to
provide the trappings of patriarchal
power and inheritance with a dignified
home offering only the structurally
unstable edifice of a flagrantly
fictional paper castle that as Cindy
points out crumbles at the slightest
touch as a hero Theodore is laughable
the formal comedy that should be
consolidated in his marriage to isabella
is transformed by his feebleness as a
vision of man into a more satirical
comedy centered on the catastrophic
weakness of patriarchy's privileged sons
this is the catastrophic positive
buoyancy that interests me in Otranto
opposite to the Nautilus whose
positive buoyancy carries it to
catastrophe Oh Toronto's catastrophes
offer to lift us by way of their
hilarity to a place where the death of
particular institutions of power takes
on a festive energy and we are invited
to revel in the ruins of their dignity
I've Hank all the speakers for the
richness of their papers and the brevity
of their remarks which brings us out
right pretty much on time for a full
discussion with your questions leading
us I will ask you to give me a chance
just to pause after you ask your
question so that I can paraphrase it so
that your question will be picked up on
the microphone and make the record
coherent when it is reviewed I open the
floor I would actually like to see Sean
John
here's part of the river which is again
started open or close together
the tradition of the folly or the
playful which virtually always expect
it's not hated
you only need to get the rokoko say they
want you get a little asserts its so
I've seen up a paper mache and the idea
of starry hills being told on your terms
a kind of network description of the
Gothic not not forgotten itself
series of describe statements
condensations a little bit like it's not
book
the pay our own clothes before I ice
trying to person
think about that I'm so very well in
there it's small manifested fake
in the dream John benders question is
about the artifice of the folly and of
the paper-mache world created around
such a folly and even including the
language as if I heard you right of the
descriptive language creating that
fairytale castle in the mind I was that
directed particularly at a Tron but
anyway that you were asking Shawn was
when he when you called what he was
doing a kind of description of the
Gothic rather than the Gothic itself
right your your your images as I guess
in my term annex raíces of the Gothic
rather than right and so that's what I
would like to hear you talk about
because what I was struck by is that
each of you of the rest of you were
doing something that I didn't do which
was to set up a kind of isomorphism
between these formal patterns that you
were registering although Jessie that
might not be true but like free for you
Shawn there's an isomorphism between
this computer formalization of cognitive
processes right and these architectural
forms and then that leads to a kind of
claim or a the the stakes of that it
involves sort of reimagining the moment
of the 18th century as a connectionist
rather than a
action SS functionalist right and then
in you know for Cindy there is an
isomorphism established between these
syntactic patterns that you were
noticing and and I guess I ultimately
wrote down genre right so certain yeah
as well as arc and then you know for
Eugenia there was this isomorphism and
perhaps yours was the strongest argument
that moved from this formal isomorphism
to a claim about in this case politics
so I was really struck by that that sort
of the repetition of that structure to
the way we make arguments and so I just
wanted to sort of throw that out is what
I picked out from John's question rather
than a building I mean I I I guess what
I would I guess the question bears on on
how how deep were willing to allow the
aesthetic to run if it's I mean the
notion of so I I guess I would I would
object to them not objects that's too
strong but I would object in a soft
sense I suppose to that so that to the
notion to the notion of Strawberry Hill
as a model I would understand you asleep
Jack to the notion of or strenuous you
know and instead I mean I think of it
really as a residue to a process you
know that one of the things we forget I
think categorically forget about
Strawberry Hill is how many times it was
remodeled and rebuilt and it was often
remodeling and rebuilt not simply by
Walpole himself but in consultation with
other people and also with other people
in mind like people that he wanted to
visit or people that he wanted to have
live there often other men but not
always other men and what's left now is
of course an object that we tour and it
stands as a kind of ornament book of
Gothic style but it wasn't built that
way
it was built over time I mean there's
some of the things I'm saying here are
relatively obvious but but when I say
that I I would experience it more as a
residue than as a model is that it's
it's clearly a residue of a process that
unfolded over years over about 30 years
that were also Walpole the most
productive literary years but not as a
model in the sense that
it's something that was ever held in the
mind hole and then you know and then
projected and the way that sometimes we
think of models as conceptual and also
as material why you say residue of a
process rather than yeah well I think a
lot of the joy of Strawberry Hill was
you know with changing it working with
it you know continually building that's
why the paper mache or the wall paper so
I mean if it's in stone it's in stone
but if it's wall paper you could throw
it up and see how it looks and unchanged
but then of course it's left over but
the thing is left there after the
remodeling has been done because he
wants for it not to be an object he
right Shawn me yeah because to be an
object is to be reduced in some way and
you want it to be an index of a process
rather than you want it to have positive
which is why I think there's an
interesting connection between the way
you're sort of are producing this the
sign of genre as it's happening right as
it sort of unfolding Cindy and and what
in this sort of I think conceptual or
theoretical investments of your argument
Shawn in process rather than say object
add to that to go back to John's
observation about the the ghost right
like the giant the image of the giant
ghost moving through this very small you
know house I think that that the way
that bodies move through the actual
house of Strawberry Hill is also
something that that the space is doing I
don't I don't know that it was designed
exactly right it wasn't like modelled so
that you know bodies would move in a
particular way but and this is something
that I'd never thought about until I
actually found myself in the space
because you kind of have to be in it to
realize the proportions of it like the
proportions are off from what you're led
to imagine you would feel from images of
it and I think that's part of what it's
doing but this was this was brought home
pretty starkly the first time that I
went so this isn't like fall 24
13 and it was the first time that I'd
gone after the restoration and the
docent that was kind of showing me
around originally took me up the
staircase and on the banisters they had
these you know beautiful little dear
ornaments that I refers to the the
family seal or you know something and on
the second floor one of them was missing
and like it clearly like it looked like
I had just been torn off and the docent
apologized that it was such a mess and
they hadn't you know like cleaned it up
or like you know repaired it but he said
just the day or two before someone had
come in with a giant backpack and as
they rounded a corner they just knocked
the deer right off the banister but
that's kind of what it's like to move
around in that space so just being like
a normal sized human being or maybe like
a slightly larger you know the norm you
feel you feel the odd proportions of
your body in relation to the space
around you one more thing about the
artifice and that is that I mean it's
important for us to acknowledge that I
mean the very term gothic yeah I mean
it's referring explicitly to a typeface
I mean it's referring explicitly to its
status as print and Cindy actually when
you were you know giving your
presentation one of the most absurd
lines to me is when Theodore we have he
printed a thousand kisses over clay cold
hands and uttered every expression that
despairing love could dictate I asked my
undergraduates can you imagine printing
you know that many number of kisses and
you know part of I think that the
absurdity comes through the recognition
that we're dealing with printed words
you know here on a page and so you know
I think there's a strong attention to
drawing our attention to the the the
status of objects as codes for something
and you know the clock is a code for
something it's signal's time but the
conception of time has really kind of
matter it modeled on the movement of the
clock circularly rather than what it
actually implies
the architectural models is working
objects but there's a there's attention
in all polls on the behavior between
that fragility in one hand and his wish
to render the building permanent in the
book he published showing these rooms so
there's a and that book for Jackson to
go to your point the roofs don't really
look like that the rooms have cravings
of the much more modern minute and
significant look
in that book play into that as well
process not residue exactly but ongoing
interpenetrate 'iv and upsetting or
readjusting the perspectives you know
close to yeah yeah
yes sir yeah Zell has inverted the
relationship back to helmet
the Gothic structure provides a kind of
allegory for the way that one reads
novel and and maybe to see if we can
just bring that out a bit and I once
rusty maybe first of people alongside of
strawberry models put their Castle of
Otranto itself under model and there we
actually is in the sense that the helmet
is not pointed in fact it cracks a hole
and that bowl allows for the moonlights
to go and try other people's like
service and then there's an interior and
abalone interior passage all of which
provide an account of yeah whether or
not that functional computational model
that you offer but in case it's it's not
doesn't seem to be like a flattener on
that connection
ya know I have a second channel ceramic
is asked a question about the nature of
the castle Strawberry Hill as a
architectural edifice and the castle in
the novel as an allegory of reading for
the text yeah no that's good Jonathan
thanks for that I mean I will see two
things one's mildly technical as I
understand it which is that I mean this
is an old objection to the neural-net
model is that it would presumably be
incapable of having higher-order
representations of itself and this is
Gerry photos objection to the but it but
that's I'm that's actually been
empirically disproven that there have
been neural networks that return
descriptions of themselves so it's
that's a in the sense that that kind of
like higher order lower order this sort
of that structural distinction that we
seem to detect in human cognition
between higher and lower order processes
that that can be simulated by a neural
network in the same way that a neural
network could be simulated by a
functionalist system but the you know
the other thing that I wanted to say
this really I guess goes back to my
earlier work on thinking about Walpole
thinking about the Castle of Otranto and
especially about you know his other
great Gothic experiment the mysterious
mother is the extent to which the
illusions of interior tea that emerge or
the effects of interior tea I'm talking
about human psychic and Terry already
emerge in a complex cognitive ecology a
kind of a dialogue or an elaborated
dialogue a relationship between persons
and spaces all right so that that's I
mean that would be I guess in a way my
we call it fallback position or where I
draw my line in the sand is is that
there's Walpole doesn't seem to me at
least to be sketching out a model which
I in some ways actually argue for in the
last in the last book in which I'm now
starting to argue against of a strict
kind of
we might almost call a quasi duelist
model of the you know of conscious and
then subconscious interior tea but
instead elaborates that and these in in
these ecological relationships of person
and place I'd like to elaborate on that
too on Jonathan's point about depth
being interpretive not just
psychological but generic and part of
the reading process that passage where I
pointed out that Manfred the leaves and
comes back and we have that little
textual space of other time other place
it's something that the Gothic develops
especially well it's kind of pulling
apart time and space
think of the monk when
Ambrosio sinks on into Matilda's arms I
am thine and fifteen minutes later and a
hundred and thirty pages later he pops
back up in a different volume and and
it's over and there are so many textual
subterranean passages that way that you
know other novels make use of too but I
really think that's one of the kind of
architectural innovations of the Gothic
I'd like to build on that and I think
possibly also respond to Ruth's
observation about the the vault the
physical vulnerability of the built
environment in relation to the the
bodies that move the human bodies that
move through it but I think that I think
one of the things that's funny to me at
least about the gothic ruins like like
the castle in the Castle of Otranto has
to do with with the way that the novel
is playing with time and in another way
and the relationship between time and
ruination like historical processes of
ruination because one of the things that
the Gothic this gothic story is doing is
it ruins things instantaneously right so
it's like you think of the Gothic ruin
as something that has been ruined over
some extended period of time
and therefore you know speaks to
historical time in a particular way is
like evidence of the way material
doesn't last you know when you think
about time in a big-picture way but but
what's happening - just for example like
the castle here is it's just being
destroyed right before your eyes it's
being it's being ruined immediately and
so I think that I think that that's
something that I think this was kind of
like an ongoing project of Walpole's in
in a certain way I think he was
interested in what happens when you like
what you make when you ruin something
and so that's that's one of the things
that I think the castle is he's doing
with the castle in this story yeah this
yeah is there I'm seeing if I got a
picture of that in my edition and Ed I
think right I mean I said I've been
trilha quite a couple ways you could do
that but I yes think so yeah
what's at stake also what's at stake in
the witness novel is teaming between
bite them oh I mean I totally persuaded
by each of these absolutely virtuosic
allegorical readings of form totally I
love it I do I mean come on I do that we
all do that when we teach you know I
just did it with my undergraduates you
know we talked about interruption this
inability to follow who's speaking right
as a sort of you know objective
correlative for the thematics of
usurpation etc etc I can do it
and I and I think you know and I swayed
and by these sorts of arguments I just
was trying to think about what it would
look like to resist doing it whether we
can resist doing it either just in a
like in a sort of banal way you know
whether reading is always I mean in a
sense it is always comprehension you
know we're not reading just morphemes
right we're always reading at a
syntactic level and therefore at the
level of meaning and so you know so
there's that and then there's also just
this sort of disciplinary force of that
move from form to to meaning and so
really I'm just being I don't know /
versus maybe I just I'm just really
curious as a kind of intellectual
theoretical you know endeavor game
I don't what what you know what it what
would happen if you didn't do that and
then maybe all that happens is a kind of
lame like Dyke sis right or you know
it's like look they look at all these
exclamation points
well yeah but she doesn't do that but
I'm not sure I even do I'm not sure I
even did that because it's embarrass
caller Li to do that well I guess I
wanted a little more elaboration because
I don't quite get it I guess I feel
fundamentally aesthetic designed down to
the ground but oh what's that I would
say that this that if we say that the
Castle of Otranto is a game in which the
entire hundred pages is a literal
ization of the phrase go and grown too
large to inhabit it and I'm not saying
it's not designed I guess what everyone
was what's the difference in the the
kind of suggested reading or non
interpretive description that's pre
critical versus post critical well you
know the post critique stuff often
reproduces the descriptive turns turn to
arrows or ethos as you know the
alternative to hermeneutics or something
or or it sometimes the form it takes is
an interest in the phenomenology of
reading or and so what that says to me
is that whatever is being longed for or
are described in these theoretical
positions it's not actually being
fulfilled that the desire is not
actually a desire for literality because
there has to be something more at stake
in what we do than that and it has to be
called ethics or politics or the eros of
art or whatever right
so I think I'm mostly just interested in
the theoretical project and kind of like
pushing back against not against the
drive for pure description but against
the idea that that that that's actually
what people who are calling for the turn
are doing and then maybe it may be done
to say maybe they're not doing it
because we can't do it but I think
they're not doing it because in Heather
loves case she cannot abide the idea of
not giving a political account of
beloved that is intolerable to us CF my
forthcoming in ask a follow-up question
though of Sandra is that all right about
this I I wonder if like this is such an
earnest question I want to know your
what you think is Walpole's description
of the villa doing to his house what an
actual descriptive reading would do to
the text would do to the novel that is
like the description of the villa is
this I mean I find it this incredibly
puzzling text I've tried really hard to
use it you know to make use of it but
it's but it's just a catalog I mean
that's all that's what it is it's just a
catalog and soon so there's a part of me
that's like like you know I'm I'm good
at reading I'm good at interpreting I
can interpret a catalogue there's
actually something about it that stymies
interpretation you know you kind of find
yourself you're just you're just reading
a stark list with very little every once
in a while there's a little bit of
contextual information but very little
and so if you read it from cover to
cover what you've done is just taken
this descriptive view room-by-room of
all the spaces in a way that doesn't
leave you with anything really I mean I
guess you have some knowledge of what
was there you know what kinds of objects
were there but
is that the kind of I mean I'm really
interested in that that form actually
and so I really so this week we read
Roderick random and I'm in doing
research on the Nauvoo I came across
this essay from like 1979 by a linguist
who's like literary critics don't have
any respect for us linguists just like
serious scientific structural linguists
and so everyone talks about rent a small
at style but nobody ever says how his
style works so this guy goes ahead and
gives this you know morphology
linguistic morphology of the structure
of smallest sentences and then goes on
to show like how this structure is
repeated and it so it's like you know I
don't know subordinate clause plus verb
but you know I mean I I can't do it
myself but I so I was like so kids folks
what do we you know what do we like
they're supposed to write x-ray C's this
week of something they can either write
I not you know doing it a link a verbal
ekphrasis of an object they can do it
you know they can I don't care 3d print
an object that's like you know a reading
of the castle of Trento so I was like
you know what is this what we should be
doing is this what the fulfillment of
Heather loves call for description would
look like and we were we sort of decided
well a we don't know how to do that
we're not trained to do that but you
know I forget what B was you know yeah
I'm interested in what happened to
morphological sort of thinking after
structuralism and you know it seems to
me that this return to formalism it is
not weirdly a return to structuralism or
even some aspects of post structuralism
whereas you would think that a true
commitment to pure description would
look a lot more like structural
linguistics than like anything else but
we don't want that I don't think we want
that I mean I might but I don't think
you know how their love does because
like failure of interpretation or is
this interpretation that's the sublime
so like you Bianca like looks at the
helmet and can't describe it because
that's part of that's part of the
theater the the sublime beaming kind of
the failure of representation and so
then the failure they're kind of
funniness essentially a couple of canto
V part the failure of us of why Bianca
can't it's not that Bianca can't
describe it she I mean you could say she
can't she also won't I mean it comes at
the end of that whole encounter with
Manfred where she's continually using
language in a way to you know is in it
so she's continually picking up sort of
literal syntax as a way of resisting
what Manfred wants to know which is
where's Isabella or you know what is
Isabella feel about Theodore or whatever
right so it's a strategy or at least it
comes at the end of a of a passage or an
exchange that's very much about a
strategic use of indexicality or a sort
of refusal of you know to to to to
represent that is not a kind of
ontological failure pissed illogical
failure but uh but a strategy so that's
my and it's funny you know it's part of
the wit of that moment is bianca is this
sort of wily servant figure her you know
her lines but it's like in direction of
speech right
yes that's a relationship but I wonder
like there's an option besides to in
response interpretation or a resistance
of interpretation
maybe there's something like that
brian says arrives with romanticism but
maybe while you're reading it arrives
with the heart of this question is about
the relation of aesthetics and cognition
in interpretation I mean Shawn what do
you think of this idea that that a
literal criticism raises the specter of
a non cognitive aesthetics that's what I
heard you say initially yes it's an
interesting question and in a sense it
cuts to the core of what it is that we
think we do when we're thinking whether
we think that we're fundamentally about
Association or whether we think we're
about storage and processing I'm
thinking I'm still thinking about about
Walpole's relationship to description
and as Gina pointed out the his most
descriptive text has the description of
the villa which was remodeled you know
published twice and it's different in
each but that it its sustaining my sense
is that it it works if you read it and
you're not satisfied and that's why
there's a ticket to go visit the house
yes that's included yeah because that
description has a in as much as it's a
human document I mean in as much as it's
an informational document you know art
historians can use it to establish
provenance it could be it's it is of
Walpole's documents it is the one that
could most easily be converted into a
database I think these are the things
that he had here's where they were but
but it's also the document that most
reply maybe not most but for a fact
let's say most relies on the space that
it imagines and that in fact it draws
you to the space that it imagines in
which which is to say that it's a it's
in a kind of an intense dialogue with an
associative dialogue I think with with
the house that it records so yeah this I
I guess I would say that in you might
call it I mean it's non narrative but it
is a narrative of space yeah I mean yeah
just to be clear I mean that's the other
thing that it's been quiet it's been
pretty rigorously established that it
wasn't designed as an auction catalog so
much as it was designed as a hand list
for a tour that you weren't taking yet
but it also sets up I mean I think this
is kind of a speculative statement but I
think it also sets up a certain
encounter with the objects once you
actually take your ticket and go there
that itself is is designed to be
unsatisfying like I think that I mean
just just kind
based on my own experience of you know
having read this description become very
enamored of the idea of getting a better
experience with these objects right like
this description is telling me a little
bit but what it's really telling me is
that I don't really know what this thing
is I would understand it better if I saw
it you know in in actual space ideally
if I saw it in Strawberry Hill right and
I know there's been like all of these
attempts to get the objects back into
the house so people can have that
experience but but then you know you
come to the object and I know I mean I'm
saying this as a literary scholar who's
been trying to like work with material
objects or read material objects like
you get there and you're in front of it
and you're like that's cool it's a
little bit like the exclamation points
right it's like that's cool but I I'm
not having some kind of revelatory
experience unlocked simply by having
come into contact with it so it's it's
like it begins a narrative of of
continual unsatisfying contact with with
the object you know I was just thinking
as you said this one of the we read
Virginia Woolf and our my graduate class
and the essay is that mrs. and mrs.
Brown where she talks about the
experience of reading a lot of 18th
century texts tristram shandy and Pride
and Prejudice as completely satisfying
when you Don all you want to do is pick
it up read it again understand it better
unlike her the night late 19th century
and her contemporaries but I wonder I
mean we've been talking about the gothic
architectural II and literally as
unsatisfying would that fall out of that
kind of and does that wolffian criticism
even play a part and you are you know
finding a middle ground and interpretive
ly in any sense is just very quickly I
think I mean the the the other it's
waffles other gothic experiment I think
that you know the mysterious mother that
is his argument about the relationship
between
a desire and and the object and and it
as it as a play that was famously
published but that famously publicized
but withheld from view and that the
house again reenacts that as a play that
you can you can ever quite see it's it's
announced in the catalog you're not
allowed to read it in the book their
closet to like that one kind of
secretive space and the the drawings no
longer exist right I mean even when you
go visit the house now they'll tell you
this is the Boclair closet where the
drawings of the mysterious mother were
displayed for Walpole's own private
enjoyment but I think those drawings are
none okay sorry
I'm completely I'm completely wrong but
anyway there is this kind of there is
the set up of Revelation and the
manuscript for the play was kept in a
cabinet there seems there's several
encounters of people with those drawings
after having read about them they
celebrated drawings and and there's a
marvelous note in one of the auction
catalogues when when when they when they
were finally seen and he just simply
says they're actually rather ordinary
and out of context there's nothing to
recommend them right right yes Sarah so
I was just thinking about this question
about whether there's a third way of
reading between description and
interpretation and I was wondering if
the phenomenology or a phenomenological
account of reading is is is not our
answer to what that third way is because
when you two get to read in the
phenomenological way as they take it is
to give a report of the encounter with
the text which is not the same as giving
a description because it's not
pretending that it's not filtered
through a consciousness and you know
we're trying to think about well what is
it that I'm trying to do when I write
about the gospel of a Toronto or any
other tax and I
thinking it's something like or what I
think I'm doing is asking myself how
it's asking to be interpreted and of
course you could say well that's you
know that's whatever your answer to that
question is is itself an interpretation
but I feel like the the phenomenological
answer would be the in telling you how I
think this text is asking to be
interpreted that is my account of what
it is like to encounter this text and to
say but it is offering up these
different possibility of these different
ways of reading it and that my job as
the critic is to articulate those and
make them explicit in some way so I
don't I just was wondering if
phenomenology is a helpful way of
thinking about a third term in addition
to interpretations yeah the question is
about phenomenology as an alternative to
the descriptive or the interpretive
methods can I say something generator
this is kind of directed to you but I
mean for me this is um I mean it's
really kind of one of Walpole's
most lasting legacies and we get that in
the first preface is that you know I
wish this novel had more of a moral than
that the sins of future generations
would be visited upon it it's kind of an
open vowel of kind of you know the
content lists or the you know the you
know our foolishness in in attempting to
you know begin to ask interpretive
questions of it I mean it seems to me
that you know he is he's very canny or
aware and you know seeking to promote a
different kind of reading probably then
you know the realist tradition of the
novel but you know certainly you know I
think it's a you know it's a different
way of looking at art I think
see the sort of semicolon in your
subjective realism attacks like mrs.
Dalloway has a different kind of yeah
well I mean it's it's an open question I
mean this is certainly you know one of
the you know key texts of you know I
would describe of modernist realism and
that you know the depiction of the you
know the consciousness you know such
that we've never seen I think in in
literature but I mean I think that it's
also important to recognize just to
contradict what I just said that I mean
there there's a there's extraordinary
realism in the Castle of Otranto in that
sort of you know obsessional looking for
character motivations and you know John
bender sitting over there is you know I
think the kind of pioneer in recognizing
you know this work as you know offering
free indirect discourse really at a
capacity in an ever seen and it you know
if we can describe free indirect
discourse as an important feature of you
know modern narrative realism you know
it is there in this work that declares
itself to be morally content less I mean
I wouldn't I myself wouldn't be entirely
comfortable with the distinction between
realism and the gothic godless ism and
realism but and nor would I associate
realism with the adumbration of
consciousness so I guess I'm sort of I
actually take a lot of what I was saying
about literalism as an account of its
real of realism
and and for me the you know the the way
that that literalism for Walpole is a
kind of is an interest in I guess what I
saw R t'v thinking of as emblematic sort
of and you know an emblematic of the
primary the primary qualities of or
attributes of Sir
forms as you know sort of how realism
works
doors casement stairs nail bodies female
bodies right it's it doesn't when the
human figure emerges it doesn't seem to
me substantively different from the way
doors work in in the novel so that you
know that's I guess what and so oh and
as for mrs. Dalloway I actually have
started to think of that novel in
particular as a kind of apotheosis of a
literalism so extreme as to be it's kind
of hyper materiality so that like Wolf's
aesthetic is so much it's like Mondrian
it's like she color shape line you know
and that's what interests me more I
guess these days then about about mrs.
Dalloway then then consciousness we have
time for one more question in this
session yes I have a question about
funniness as it relates to to I guess
sort of a Jason or
is the genre of comedy and ethos and I
was wondering about just the and I guess
also this connects to your question
about the sort of the potential for an
aversion in the relationship between the
body and the space so that it could be
sort of a joke on the body that a sort
of perceiving the clunkiness of one's
only body in the space or either the
objects or the bodies start to seem
either funny or off and this would I
mean I I'm curious what you would think
about this but it seems like one thing
that distinguishes the funny would be
that kind of instability about like what
what is the target of the joke or the
target of the satire and that made me
also wonder about the status of the two
practices in relation to one another and
the sort of performance of in that'
toriel history of a kind of joke on the
reader and what would that do to the
sort of the target of the sort of
imminent target of the book of the joke
of the book which I suggested might be
sort of like peach we are all as you
know like does that sort of be filtering
at that adjust yeah the question is if
it's funny what's the joke right yeah
yeah and that's that's actually a
brilliant way of distilling that because
I think that what I've what I've come to
understand more and more as I've been
working on this project is that I'm less
interested in the funniness of jokes
than I am in instances of funniness
arising from an instability of maybe we
could say like relative positions I mean
I'm thinking now about you know Sean's
work on on relationships and so I'm
thinking a little bit about your
question about the prophecies but it but
it made me leap to something else which
is what I'm gonna actually talk about
maybe there's an answer to your question
here somewhere but one of the like one
of the kinds of funniness that I have
come to think about more and more is the
way that 18th century texts like the
Castle of Otranto
are funny to contemporary readers like
how they're funny to us
and funny in a way that they're not that
they're almost certainly not designed to
be right so there's no reason to think
that when Walpole was writing this that
one of the things he had anywhere in his
mind was what is this good how is going
to read to a 21st century reader but
there is a there is a certain like very
palpable kind of funniness to 18th
century prose and I think the texture of
the prose that Cindy was talking about
is a large part of it
when students for example like when we
teach these texts and students read it
for the first time they frequently like
they'll say like I don't I don't get it
or I don't understand what's going on
but they're still compelled through
something like curiosity but I think
that that's even heightened sometimes
into thinking it's funny what they're
looking at is funny and it doesn't mean
they feel like there's a joke that
they're in on there it just means
there's something like I'm trying to put
my I'm trying to come up with a way of
describing what that something is that
they're picking up when they say yeah
this was really funny I didn't you know
like what and then the follow-up
question is like what what is going on
right what's happening but I think that
that is is coming out of the instability
of the relationship between reader and
text and particularly like you know
reader in her own moment in history and
text kind of like speaking from its
moment in history and so so yeah like
wall to go back to my point about the
way that Walpole is playing with
instantaneous ruins
I almost feel a little bit like his
multiple preface --is are like speeding
up that process of a text kind of
revealing itself as a different text
through time through one addition to the
next right it kind of radically reframes
the text in a way that we might see as
literary historians or we might
interpret as happening like in this kind
of organic way just because you the
world changes through time and so the
things in it change as well but I think
that wall post kind of saying like know
that I mean me
but also we can do this and and generate
those effects kind of immediately in the
here and now I'm not going to end the
conversation here but pause it with the
note that one of the pleasures are among
the many pleasures of a country-house
weekend not shooting birds not chasing
foxes but carrying on the conversation
into the next session so Tallyho
[Applause]